der erste weltkrieg gilt als
urkatastrophe des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
so jedenfalls brannte er sich ins
kollektive gedächtnis ein
wohl mit recht waren grausamkeit nicht
zu überbieten
zudem ruinierten sich alle
kriegsführenden länder total das ganze
unternehmen war ein tatsächlich
weltweites desaster
die schweiz aber blieb verschont warum
verschont heißt allerdings nicht nicht
betroffen flüchtlinge wurden gepflegt
lebensmittel waren knapp unruhen
flammten auf wie war das leben damals
vor 100 jahren in der schweiz
katja gentinetta hat dazu ein historiker
runde geladen und zwar georg kreis erika
erweisen und den militärhistoriker
rudolf jaun im ersten weltkrieg standen
sich die großmächte europas gegenüber
rund 70 millionen menschen standen unter
waffen 15 millionen menschen fanden den
tod
die schweiz beteiligte sich nicht an
diesem krieg georg rau sie sind im rat
ihrer professor für neuere allgemeine
und schweizer geschichte an der
universität basel
wie wichtig ist es dass sich auch die
schweiz des ersten weltkriegs erinnert
ich kann bei dieser gelegenheit diese
paradoxe steigerung von nationalem
selbstverteidigungs willen und illusion
ein wenig und realer abhängigkeit vom
rest der welt wahrnehmen und kann im
übrigen dann auch wahrnehmen dass die
schweiz am ende des krieges nicht die
gleiche schweiz war wie zu beginn des
krieges auf der ereignis- ebene
insbesondere im oktober 19 18 die der
wahl der abstimmungssieg über die zur
proporz initiative was bis heute ein
gerechteres war als systemen in unserem
system eingeführt hat sie haben einiges
angetippt über das wir sprechen werden
auch am schluss werden wir noch mal
schauen wurde in diese schweiz
eigentlich stand wo sie heute steht aber
vorher ist noch die erinnerung an diesen
krieg erika hebeisen die schweiz hat
sich eben nicht beteiligt an diesem
krieg sie war verschont von diesem krieg
ist es denn überhaupt angemessen sich in
der schweiz dieses krieges zu erinnern
ich denke es ist dringend nötig dass man
das tut und mir scheint auch die chance
ist jetzt vorhanden hier mit einem
offenen geschichtsbild an ein thema
heranzugehen wenn man das mit dem
zweiten vergleich also dass dieser erste
weltkrieg noch nicht so zementiert ist
was sind eigentlich die konsequenzen
oder das was man daraus für schlüsse
ziehen könnte gleichzeitig war ich aber
gerade als wir dieses buch auch zusammen
gemacht haben über abrechnet und diesem
buch kriegs und schließen zürich während
des ersten weltkriegs gehen dass sie
wird herausgegeben dass es mit
herausgeben dass wir länger uns
unterhalten haben ist dass zürich im
ersten weltkrieg oder eben während und
ich bin eine starke verfechterin von
während dass man das sehr deutlich macht
dass das wirklich eine grosse differenz
ist was krieg heißt mit militärischer
kriegsführung mit diesen großen
opferzahlen mit den wahn sehr großen
verwundeten zu allen und dem was in der
schweiz war aber das heißt nicht man
soll nicht noch überreden
sie sind historikern und kuratoren und
schweizerischen nationalmuseum sie herr
professor sie sind die thora professor
für geschichte der neuzeit und
militärgeschichte an der universität
zürich an was sollten wir uns erinnern
wenn wir uns an die schweiz im ersten
weltkrieg erinnern dann spreche ich
jetzt wirklich die getätigt haben was
ist der wichtigste kundin aus dass sich
damit der geschichte ist es die tatsache
dass es die erste generalmobilmachung
ist eine schweizer strahlkraft seit 290
hat dass nike vor der einzelnen kantone
mit dabei
dann hat ist das ein sehr widriger
neutralität schutzdienst geworden der
dann verbunden war mit problemen der
wirtschaft mit teuerung
lebensmittelknappheit heizmaterial
knappheit sie haben keine eigentliche
krise hinein gesteuert hat und letzten
endes ist militärisch auch aber
natürlich auch gesamtgesellschaftliche
erste weltkrieg seinen riesen
transformationsprozess ein konverter des
schweizerischen gesellschaften der
schweizerischen staat
wie war das werden wir sprechen sprechen
wir aber zuerst über die ganz große
landschaft die schweiz war durch ihre
geographische lage natürlich von den
kriegs mächten und leben
wir haben hier eine karte gesehen die
kleine schweiz in der mitte dieses
kontinents wie sähe in rosarot ein
gefährt gefärbt diana und mächte
frankreich großbritannien russland
serbien montenegro auch die durch die
anfangs durch diese das militärbündnis
miteinander verbunden waren und in der
mitte das deutsche reich und
österreich-ungarn die sogenannten
mittelmächte die sich im wesentlichen
gegenüber standen die schweiz eben wie
gesagt in der mitte wo der hund war die
schweiz überhaupt zu einem bestimmten
moment militärisch bedroht
sie war potenziell bedroht klima weil es
war klar dass ein krieg in europa hat im
krieg zwischen frankreich und
deutschland das war ja auch mit dem
schliefen plan so angelegt und da
bestand die möglichkeit dass die
deutschen oder die franzosen ein
entlastungsangriff machen
es war aber klar nachdem der krieg
losgebrochen ist dass die deutschen
gehen über belgien und dann war das
eigentlich nur noch die frage kommt
frankreich darf weil durch die schweiz
da hat man mit dem deutschen dass auch
schon ein bisschen also nicht
schriftlich festgelegt aber man hat das
abgesprochen und das spezifische
variante des die schweiz informiert war
dass die deutschen bei billigen gehen
durch ein abgemacht ist telegramm
während dem kaiser manöver abgemacht und
die genau staatschefs telegramm ante
portas und das drauf am 31 juli in der
schweiz ein insofern war man orientiert
nachdem der krieg dann im norden ab geht
nicht welt in frankreich war das
eigentlich es ist von beiden seiten her
noch eine möglichkeit die aber dann nie
wirklich akut geworden ist dann war noch
ob das war die idee des genau stabschef
von sprechern italien könnte die schweiz
bedrohen viele haben war behle hat ihn
immer gesagt dass er das du hast eine
phobie gesprächen war general will er an
der gewählten reber entsprechend wir
noch und sie sprechen seinen
stellvertreter an seinem haus stand er
als chef in den militärischen orden sind
sie besser bewandert
generalstabschef sprecher an das muss
sich jetzt fragen sie haben belgien
erwähnt eben deutschland ist über
welchen marschiert hätte dass der
schweiz nicht passieren können
grundsätzlich habe man das ausschließen
persönlich hat das abgeklärt gesagt ja
eine möglichkeit über die schweiz zu
gehen hat da man sich das gelände an
geschah nichts aus kempten plateau und
auch die schweizerische miliz man sagt
dann auf der kaiser hätte 19 12 das
persönliche prüft in der schweiz hält
die schweizerische miliz und schliefen
das ist quellen mäßig belegt hat gesagt
wir gehen nicht über die schweiz
wir schliefen plan heißt ein angriff
unter der verletzung der
neutralitätspflicht nach st also hat uns
das gelände gerettet in dem moment und
die da kommen wir drauf haut wächst
bereich der schweiz sagt ja die halbwegs
bereit die schweizer armee jähriger
hebeisen sie sind der kuratorin an der
waffensammlung des schweizerischen
nationalmuseums
wie war denn die schweiz bewaffnet
beziehungsweise wäre sie eigentlich
überhaupt gewappnet gewesen
sie wäre also waffentechnisch war die
schweiz nicht schlechter aufgestellt
also ich finde ganz deutlich dass man
mit dem gewehr 19.11 eben über das
schauen was macht deutschland was macht
frankreich hat man quasi die ideale
gewehrpatronen erfunden und definitiv
vor diesem krieg also in einer zeit wo
nicht über krieg geredet worden ist
morgen wird der vor der haustüre stehen
es war das maschinengewehr was er ein
wichtige waffe war in diesem
stellungskrieg dann im ersten weltkrieg
das war da das war quasi hausgemacht
was nicht da war
herfried münklers spricht davon der
trinität geschenken der deutsche
historiker darüber auch eingehend
beschreibt vom kredite der waffen für
den stellungskrieg es ist oder vom
ersten weltkrieg dass nämlich der
stahlhelm die gasmaske und die
handgranate und so dass man wie stark
das sind
produkte die eben im laufe des ersten
weltkrieges dann entstanden sind oder
rüstungsteile warum hat die schweiz 2011
sich um diese um diese bewaffnung
gekümmert war das einfach in der zeit
haben dass alle starten gemacht ich
denke eben das was ganz generell sei
dieser teil 1911 entschuldigung ich habe
das nicht dieser technologie schufa sind
dass das in der autoindustrie oder man
kann noch nicht von industrie reden oder
in jeden technischen bereich dieses
dieser versuch zu optimieren zu
verbessern die möglichkeiten
auszuschöpfen
das kann man an der waffentechnik
technologie sehr genau auch so verfolgen
und dann gleichzeitig doch eine auch
militarisierte gesellschaft also preußen
vor augen das ist dann wiederum das buch
von herrn jahren die diese
militarisierung der gesellschaft diadem
viel wert beimisst dass man gerüstet ist
sie haben von von maschinengewehr
gesprochen aber eben auch vom stahlhelm
georg kreis schätzen sie die bewaffnung
der schweizer armee gleich einige
vorweisen
im großen ganzen schon jetzt was sie
auch gesagt hätte wenn es jetzt noch
hätte länger sprechen können oder wollen
als dass die die schwere artillerie zum
beispiel die die fehlte ich weiß nicht
ob ich die flug war verwenden darf die
die war eigentlich auch sozusagen nicht
vorhanden und auch fliegen abwehr aber
man muss auch sagen dass natürlich auch
die kriegstechnik sich im laufe des
krieges rapid entwickelt hat anfänglich
war das weitgehend eine pferde armee und
die motorisierung die enorm wichtig und
als man hat sich ja ganz gut auf
eisenbahn verschiebungen eingerichtet
und war da eigentlich auf der höhe der
aufgabe aber in bezug auf motorisierung
war die armee ganz schwach man hat
privatwagen requiriert und da der wagen
allein nicht ausreicht
der auch gleich den chauffeur dazu denn
eigentlich ein auto fahren können war
1914 noch etwas heraus aber jetzt eben
der helm da mag es erstaunen dass vor
allem im vergleich zu den nachbarn
armenien das in der schweiz so lange
zugewartet wurde bis man dieses
traditionelle kappi durch einen modernen
stahlhelm ersetzte und da gibt es auch
noch sonderbarer episoden dass man einen
künstler beauftragte einen visuell
schönen eindrücklichen helm zu entwerfen
und wie man denen ich berücksichtigte
hat dieser neuenburg künstler sogar noch
schadenersatz verlangt andererseits
haben die kaffeehersteller sich dagegen
gewehrt dass sie jetzt aus dem markt
verdrängt werden weil man fest dass man
hat die bedrohung nicht ernst genommen
oder gar nicht was ich weiß jetzt nicht
man ist einfach sagen wir mal zart
abhängig einfach an der alten uniform
geblieben und dann an diesem cup und man
hat im übrigen meines wissens kollege
jahren wird mich vielleicht korrigieren
können deutschen stahlhelm produzenten
vorweg eine abfindung wegen allfälligen
copyright-verletzungen ausbezahlt weil
daneben der effektive stahlhelm der dann
1918 als er wenige monate vor kriegsende
schrittweise eingeführt wurde sehr dem
deutschen modell entsprochen aber ein
amerikanisches dass amerika nicht
eingeführt haben weil es im deutschen zu
entwenden verwechslungen also was ich
noch reinwerfen kann ist das vielleicht
gravierendste hausfeld waren die
munition ja und des ganzen krieges war
man nicht in der lage die notwendigen
munitionsvorräte zu produzieren obwohl
die schweizer munitionsbestandteile
in einem recht hohen ausmaß
uhrenindustrie zum teil
exportiert hat noch zur ausrüstung also
man muss sehen die franzosen sind mit
roten hosen eingerückt und die basler
chemie hat dann blau eingeführt die
schweiz war in so viel kann die
deutschen waren schon auffällt grün das
war modern aber so im schnitt war die
schweiz uniform mäßig eigentlich noch
dabei nicht
grundsätzliches problem was man da mit
sehen kann dass die entscheidungsträger
er darauf angewiesen waren dass diese
konnte erfahrungen auswerten konnten
also dass die schweizer armee ihre
informationen dann im krieg selber nicht
direkt bezogen jetzt etwas salopp gesagt
von der front so nun eben darauf
angewiesen waren dass sie entwickeln
können auf basis von denen informationen
die sie zusammen tragen finde ich etwas
sehr wichtiges was sie sagen das war ja
eh dass das drama eigentlich der schweiz
zusammen
ich meine es ist erwähnt worden die
kriegführung entwickelt sich enorm auf
dem gefechtsfeld und die schweiz nicht
dabei und sie verliert mit jedem jahr
und sie verliert am schluss um
jahrzehnte würde ich sagen
und dann macht sie missionen dann kommen
dann die großen missionen nach
frankreich nach deutschland um zu
schauen wie sich der krieg entwickelt
gehen wir noch mal zurück zum anfang von
kriegen haben jetzt gehört das mit der
ausrichtung war nicht ganz so
vorbereitet aber trotzdem der bundesrat
hat sehr rasch reagiert hat am zweiten
august die aufrechterhaltung der
neutralität der kläger hat die krieg
mobilen mut machen erklärt und er hat
ein general gewählt hat general ulrich
wille gewählt er hat diesen general
gewählt am parlament vorbei was für
staunen gesorgt hat dieser general war
sehr umstritten warum war er so
umstritten
oder schauen als er war seit jahrzehnten
seit den 90er jahren umstritten weil er
die ausbildung der milizarmee auf das
sogenannte preußisch deutsche modell des
drills umgestellt hat das war umstritten
und er hat dass das wusste man das aber
war von einem im welschland natürlich
umstritten
und er muss er durch das parlament
gewählt und so wie es heute auch noch
wehren und aber der bundesrat hat sich
gesagt unter einflüssen wir wollen den
willen während im parlament die
politischen fraktionen war klar
sie wollen den von sprecher das war
schon amtierende generalstabschef der
ausgewiesene man wirklich der
generalstab der auch die mobilmachung
alles geplant hat wenn der wille war
mehr eben der soldaten erzählte
truppenführer aber bis das jetzt
natürlich die frage weshalb will der
bundesrat denn wille und nicht in form
sprecher ich denke dass sie doch die
idee hatten der wille bringt aus
bildungsmäßig mehr her war es war klar
die schweizer armee braucht noch fünf
sechs wochen bis die kampffähigkeit
nachdem nach dem einrücken
da hat man ihm mehr zugetraut und dann
höchstwahrscheinlich eben seines
ausgezeichneten beziehungen nach
deutschland nicht direkt zum kaiser zum
generalstabschef
da hat er einen persönlichen direkten
zugang ich denke dass hatte mitgespielt
und das hat dann ja eine aktion bedurft
der bundesrat hat diese wahl verzögert
und er ist dann darauf hinausgelaufen
dass der wille persönlich zum von
sprecher gegangen ist in bergkirchen
fährt nach hause und habe gesagt du
eigentlich
du bist doch der bessere genau stadtchef
daher kann es nicht eigentlich eher kann
es nicht der wille ist wäre kein
generalstabschef kann er hatte keine
generalstabs das wird man nie stabschef
und dann hat der von sprecher eingelenkt
nicht und ist dann musste noch der
hofmann der bundesrat in der
freisinnigen fraktion dass die
freisinnigen waren eigentlich auch für
den von sprechern ist auf dem tisch
gestanden dass man noch gemacht dazu
machen und hat die gekehrt sogar die sp
ist dann noch auf die billige und so
kommt er gewählt werden in ihrem spät am
abend nicht das war ein wal drama
der general war installiert dann er war
umstritten sie haben es erwähnt er war
er war sehr deutschfreundlich und das
hat ja auch nicht allen gefallen
georg kreis das ist meine er hat da
eigentlich eindeutig die sympathien
gehabt zum ausdruck gebracht dass ich
hier möglicherweise der deutschschweiz
angekommen sind
eine top version sowohl der
französischen schweiz wie auch der
sozialdemokratischen schweiz also dass
hier dieser widerstand recht groß war
gegen wille und dieser widerstand konnte
während des ganzen krieges nicht
ausgeräumt werden im gegenteil auch mit
dem verhalten des generals ist diese
aversion noch stärker geworden ist sogar
auch dann stärker auch in die deutschen
schweiz hinein gegangen und hat ja dann
auch zu diesen überlegungen geführt den
general aus krankheitsgründen
abzuservieren
so weit ist es dann nicht gekommen und
man kann aber auch unter diesen
umständen auch aus anderen gründen
natürlich froh sein dass der schweiz der
ernstfall erspart blieb
mußmann koppel mit auch das innovative
die monarchie und das ist auch ein
beispiel da referiere ich nur von jemand
anderem vor dass geschrieben hat die
meuterei an der flur vor dem krieg die
deutlich zeigt wie wenig sympathie wähle
für den republikanismus hat also das
eben aus der truppe heraus bis zu einer
gewissen grad der erwartung im raum
steht wir werden nicht als nur dirigiert
wir wollen wissen aber bis hierhin
machte sinn und dieses einfach nur
ausharren und aushalten und dringen dass
es da eben auch um monaten monarchisch
disziplinarisch republikanisch was ich
da was da aufeinander trifft euch also
steht nichts zur schweiz gepasst ich
gerade sie fragt jörg rau sie haben in
ihrem buch insel der unsicheren
geborgenheit die ganze schweiz während
dieser kriegsjahr beschrieben die
schweiz war nicht teils krieges sie hat
ihre neutralität erklärt wie wichtig
warten überhaupt diese neutralität ihren
sein
hat sie der schweiz geholfen müssen also
einmal im selbstverständnis der zeit war
die neutralität einerseits eine
selbstverständlichkeit die erklärung die
sie erwähnt haben war großer motor eine
fortschreibung der erklärung die man
schon 18 70 beim deutsch französischen
krieg von sich gegeben hat aber im
unterschied bis hin zu heutigen
einschätzungen war die neutralität
eigentlich nicht so sehr aus selbstzweck
gedacht dass die schweiz für die
verrechtlichung von neutralität da ist
dann wirklich ein instrument und das
eigentlich eine hohe bereitschaft auch
eben dann bei wille und anderen
da war diese neutralität schnell
preiszugeben sofern es den
schweizerischen interessen dient also
bis hin eben im sommer 15 von wille die
meinungsäußerung dass jetzt der richtige
moment ist bei beim künftigen sieger
dabei zu sein und gut wenn das dann
gleich noch deutschland oder die zentral
möchte während andere seite halten bitte
was hat ihn davon abgehalten ihre eine
frage also gut das war eine
meinungsäußerung und es hätte natürlich
schon einen es wäre kein
selbstverständlicher akt gewesen und man
könnte eigentlich sagen das hätte dann
kollidiert mit einem breiten
selbstverständnis in der schweiz aber
jetzt neutralität auch wenn man
dogmatisch sagen kann das beschränkt
sicherlich auf kriegs allianzen im
geführten krieg nicht einmal in bezug
auf vorbereitungsgespräche aber die
schweiz hat sich auch nicht auf den
wirtschaftskrieg vorbereitet und hier
stellt sich natürlich dann auf eine ganz
andere dramatischere acht die frage von
abhängigkeit
und man hat eigentlich auch sich soweit
vorbereitet dass man sagt man könnte
etwa zwei monate autonom sein und nach
würde eigentlich die wichtige
ernährungsversorgung garantiert über
einen verbündeten so dass eigentlich ein
kollege max mittel gesagt hat neutral
für 60 tage
und ich weiß jetzt nicht wie weit wird
dann eigentlich noch auf die vielleicht
auch doch noch wichtige innenpolitische
seite der neutralität zu reden kommen
denn das müsste unbedingt das was ich
gerade ansprechend und ich meinen sie
haben es gesagt
der wille war deutschlands ich ihre
motive ganz sicher nicht
deutschfreundlich man hat auch mit der
jeweiligen kultur sich eher verbunden
gefühlt war die neutralität auch
irgendwie eine klammer zwischen diesen
verschiedenen landesteilen innerhalb der
armee wir haben wahrscheinlich letzten
endes schon
man muss aber die kasse diese
bereitschaft von ihnen krieg zu gehen
schon relativieren ehre er war jemand
der ja sehr ironisch sarkastisch
geschrieben hat und das hat er auch mal
so gesagt nicht da sagen er war ein
glänzender konzert und auch er hat ja
eine leichte fehler gehabt aber es gibt
also absolut nichts irgendwie von
mobilmachung vorbereitungen von
operativen vorbereitungen und hier
möchte ich es noch die militärische
seite der neutralität normaler aufnehmen
was natürlich im ersten weltkrieg
da vorher völlig klar war eben 60 tage
mit der schweizer mischformen wir den
gegner abhalten den hin und dann wenn
wir eine chance haben ist das mit dem
feind des feindes das war erklärt das
war im in der ganzen offizierskorps
völlig klar
und nur so kann es überhaupt gehen nicht
und das war und das war auch angedacht
dass eben dann wenn der feind des landes
kommt mit dem machen wie es im
mittelland und nicht an der grenze und
steht an der grenze und das zu stoppen
und zu verzögern und dann kommt dieser
hauptkampf für wenige tage und dann
schauen wir wie es ist nach dem da
spielt man mit der neutralität die man
dann aufgibt
jetzt gab es ja eine andere figur die
sich
sehr deutlich zu wort gemeldet dass
spitäler der schriftsteller baselbieter
schriftsteller und kurz später 1919
nobelpreisträger der an einer wichtigen
rede vor der neuen helvetischen
gesellschaft gesagt hat wir müssen an
dieser neutralität festhalten wir dürfen
keine billige parteinahme macht es ist
so einfach für uns ihre kreise
was war denn diese neutralität auch für
die schweizerische gesellschaft in
dieser zeit aber ich denke was über die
jetzt gerade gesagt hat das war wm war
es klar die kriegspropaganda oder die
die politik der politische diskurs
innenpolitisch war ja wir sind neutral
wir haben die neutralität erklärt und
ich denke auch mit dieser räte von
später die dann so berühmt wurde der
erste weltkrieg war doch für breite
bevölkerungskreise so einer praxis test
für die neutralität also nachher hat man
doppelt an die neutralität geglaubt auch
wenn sie natürlich relativ frau dass sie
in diesem wirtschaft krieg auf alle
arten geritzt wurde aber ob die
kombination von wenn ich dieses bild mir
wieder fragen für ihre von diesem
bundeshaus das auf einem fels gebaut von
brandung umwoben das ist ein postkarten
sich das verbunden gekoppelt mit dieser
neutralität als erfahrung auch wenn die
wirtschaftlich nicht eingehalten wurde
denke ich für viele ist das eine eine
verbindung mit der grenz besetzung 1914
bis 1918 dass es sich viel tiefer
nochmal verankert hat als das sind wir
das macht die schweiz aus aber die
sprache spezieller hat ja wirklich
deutlich gesagt was ich sein wie nicht
so bequem bleiben wie neutrales wäre zu
bequem wenn wir uns quasi an wenn wir
uns annehmen würden wenn wir vorteile
ziehen werden wir müssen quasi die
schweiz so realisieren wie wir sie
wollen also das war eigentlich seine
botschaft jeder die er gemacht hat sagt
davon ab wo wollen wir jetzt reden denn
die neutralität meinte und meinte auch
heute noch primär die neutralität des
staates
und mag sein ich denke auch in diese
richtung das für die gesellschaft für
die basis wichtig war sich vorzustellen
dass der staat und die gesellschaft
insgesamt und die identität was immer
einigermaßen neutral ist was aber
absolut nicht ausschloss dass man
energisch partei ergriff für die eine
oder andere krieg seite also ist auch
ein teil des selbstverständnisses dass
die neutralität nicht die einzelnen
bürger auch bürgerinnen so weit sie
damit gedacht wurden
relevant ist und später hat da
eigentlich abend eigentlich an
selbstdisziplin appelliert zwischen
staat und den bürgern haben wir die
medien und die medien haben eigentlich
auch nicht deren neutralität unterwerfen
wollen und haben eigentlich erstaunlich
eindeutig anfänglich für die eine oder
andere seite sympathien bekundet und das
hat eigentlich wie gesagt wenn ich
dieser sogenannte graben hat trotz
dieses guten auftritt von später der
immobilie nicht der einzige war in jener
zeit hat eigentlich nicht bewirkt dass
man hier mit größerer zurückhaltung sich
zu dieser zu diesen kriegs fragen
einstellen
auch bis hin dass dann bei den
transporten von von kriegs verwundeten
wenn da dann zb deutsch schweizer
soldaten ein cordon bildeten um die
waggons zu schützen vor den
übertriebenen sympathien etwa der
frankophonen freiburg
dann wurden die soldaten der gleichen
armee als salbe beschimpfen also dass
das geht weiter durch den ganzen
sie haben es schon angedeutet ich wir
haben jetzt über das militär gesprochen
die politik etwas außen vor gelassen
weil in dem moment wirklich das militär
am zug
es gab ja aber eben auch die wirtschaft
es gab die unternehmen die in dieser
zeit wirtschaften zum teil sehr gut
wirtschaften die im gegensatz zu den
unternehmen im ausland eben weniger
getroffen waren sie haben profitiert von
dem krieg waren sie haben sie damit
gegen die neutralität verstoßen georg
kreis ich möchte auf keinen fall jetzt
irgendwie dogmatischer interpret von
neutralität sein
ich kann einfach sagen dass das
völkerrecht das damals geltende
völkerrecht das nicht verbot wohl sagen
wir mal bis heute wenn es sich um
staatsbetriebe wie gesagt eine
munitionsfabrik in altdorf handeln würde
die müssten eigentlich dann ihren handel
einstellen mit den kriegsparteien aber
das bisschen als es geht da nicht nur um
die getarnten munitionsteile so als
gebundene kupferteile oder wie das ist
so ein eigentliche waffen und das geht
ja bis bekommt damals bis in den auch in
dem zweiten weltkrieg bis heute dass man
eigentlich private unternehmen können
auch rettungsinstrumente exportieren
also man weiß dass die um fabriken
beispielsweise umgestellt haben auf
teile die für munition gebraucht werden
konnten
pazifist in der schweiz haben diesen
objekten vorgeworfen dass sie damit
quasi kriegs verlängert werden konnten
kann man das so sagen oder war das
wirklich punkten das war natürlich ein
gutes skandalisierung sein argument
nicht mehr das war sehr viele im ersten
weltkrieg das ist gigantisch oder diese
munitions bedarf
die briten haben unsere ministerium
errichtet das muss man sehen
zur eu uhrenindustrie sind es
interessante man die figuren das ist die
zeit zu unterrichten
da kommen sie sehr schnell umstellen und
das exportieren deshalb doch schon ein
bisschen high tech mit drin und die die
munitionsfabrik kationen der schweiz war
eben größtenteils privat auch die
schweizer armee hat eigentlich immer
gedrückt ihr privaten vor bekannten ist
müsst ihr endlich scheint dass die
munition für die schweiz produziert und
es ging nicht und dann hat man wimmis
gründen soll aber wie miss wurde ist es
19 19 aufgegangen
das ja es war eine private mail
applikation die erlaubt war
das muss man solche arbeiten das war
dann doch zu geräten nicht meine das ist
gigantisch weil der erste weltkrieg das
ist ein artillerie- trick den ehrlichen
tagelangen bombardements bevor die ihm
von drei überhaupt anker und
gleichzeitig wurde diese neutralität
aufgehebelt durch die washington post
tutorials ökonomik suisse es gab ja die
die anfang möchte die die mittelmächte
sozusagen aus hindern wollten und
eigentlich dafür sorgen wollen dass die
schweizerischen exporte eben quasi zu
ihnen gehen und nicht zu den
mittelmächten war das quasi kriegs
entscheiden konnten die unternehmen da
sich behaupten konnten sie trotzdem gut
wirtschaften oder haben sie sich dem
untergeordnet ich würde es nochmal etwas
öffnen dass er diese frage haben sie
profitiert natürlich hat letztlich die
wirtschaft bereit profitiert aber es war
durchaus auch krisenzeit und das war ja
nicht vier jahre lang hat man gleich
profitiert und man hat gewirtschaftet
und über den krieg hinaus auch noch mal
eine krise dann damit aufgefangen im
vergleich natürlich mit dem umfeld hat
man von diesem krieg wirtschaftlich
profitiert aber ich glaube nicht in
diesem ausmaß oder ich würde sagen man
muss diese andere seite auch anschauen
was sind die optionen dieser
firmen und dass die auch in diesem buch
und da referiere ich auch wieder nur was
andere besprechen oder erforscht haben
dieses kleinere unternehmen in
winterthur für textilien
wenn man da mal ein bisschen näher dran
geht es ist auch sehr viel unsicherheit
drin und wo kann man noch investieren
und wo kriegt man nach der wiesn uns
weiß also dieses ist ich finde es gibt
sie zwei flughöhen wenn man über diese
wirtschaftsgeschichte spricht und das
ist das skandalös ihren alleine von den
profiteuren das findet greift einfach zu
kurz aber es gibt natürlich diese
geschichte wichtig ist ja sie haben das
angebot ist war für diese unternehmen
derzeit wahnsinnig schwierig zu planen
es ging auch war auch schwierig an
rohstoff zu kommen wir haben trotzdem
irgendwie versucht sie mussten wollten
sich als unternehmen erhalten
sie sprechen das an in ihrem buch georg
kreis diese unternehmen kamen auch aus
einem liberalen wirtschaftsverständnis
heraus es war für sie irgendwie klar wir
machen hier unsere gesinnt unternehmen
wir sind nicht teil des staates die auf
jeden fall und bei unternehmen spielt
auch immer die längere
zukunftsperspektive eine große rolle
also auch bei unklaren zukunft
horizonten
wie weit kann man gehen aber auch dass
man eben sich möglichst nicht
einschränken lassen will von der einen
oder anderen partei also eine frage wäre
ja auch die ist immer wieder aufgetaucht
wie weit zb unternehmer der deutschen
schweiz aus sympathien er die die eine
krieg also die die zentral möchte
bedient hätten aber im zweifelsfall hat
man wie im fall von saurik lastwagen am
liebsten in beiden richtungen exportiert
und zum teil kommt dann im übrigen auch
noch der wichtige markt der usa hinzu
also mann mann versuchte möglichst unter
diesen restriktionen
so ist ein normales wobei allerdings bei
der verknappung sowohl der rohstoffe wie
auch der produkte spielte dann oft der
preis überhaupt keine rolle also man man
konnte eigentlich zu jedem hohen preis
liefern
meine die die bezüge auch bereits
sprechen wir jetzt über die gesellschaft
sprechen wie wir die menschen in diesem
land weisen sie haben ihr buch schon
mehrmals erwähnt trotzdem die schreiben
über zürich wie ging es den menschen in
dieser in diesem zürich wie haben sie
den krieg erlebt wie haben sie das
mitbekommen was was fans bar statt
ja das ist das was das buch leisten kann
ich glaube man kann einfach muss von den
menschen reden einerseits und man kann
nicht von krieg reden weil da kriegen
meine zeit ist in der an massiven wandel
von statten geht dass das krisenhafte ja
extrem anziehen 16 17 wirklich not auch
und knappheit und wie lebensmittel
lebensmittelknappheit und dann aber eben
von wem reden wir hier drinnen gibt es
zum beispiel dieses schöne foto von der
frau die am tennisspielen ist gut
gekleidet frisch gekämmt und das ist
eine realität während im ersten
weltkrieg für die fabrikanten gab ihnen
aus wald aus dem zürcher oberland
während es die ganz anderen gibt und da
finde ich gibt es auch spannende
erfahrungen die eben auch eine
geschichte haben von einer von einer
dauer also dieses diese mobilisierung
dann die viele männer die im militär
sind diesen alltag irgendwie bewältigen
müssen die viele langeweile die neben
dem dritten also diese komische
kombination von von regel von vielen
menschen die
einst gemacht werden müssen und und aber
auch der langeweile und gleichzeitig die
frauen die in diese rolle hineinwachsen
mittelschicht frauen zum beispiel die
dann geht das gemeindebüro die
gemeindeverwaltung übernimmt ein schönes
beispiel und im briefwechsel mit ihrem
mann in anderer grenze oder in der grenz
besetzung deutlich wird wie sie sich
zunehmend in dieser rolle findet und
auch wächst wächst mit ihren töchtern
zusammen also dass es familien systeme
sind denken wäre ohne familie war hat es
viel schwieriger das ist für mich so ein
beispiel dass das zeigt wie die töchter
dann auch ihre rollen übernehmen
die einigen dann noch in die romo die im
magnet auch in die romandie während im
krieg und macht da die reha nach
sozusagen und schickt dann aber auch
nahrungsmittel also das was dabei so zu
bekommen ist und es ist so ein
zusammenspiel und dann gibt es noch
diesen städtischen alltag von
künstlerkreisen die noch mal eine ganz
andere welt die aber eine welt die
möglich bleibt während dem ersten
weltkrieg in zürich mit da das stichwort
diese kreise haben es gibt nicht die
menschen und es gibt einfach definitiv
viele möglichkeiten die erhalten bleiben
ist die schicht abhängig wie viel not
man erfährt und ich glaube schon dass
diese sind dann die die bäuerliche welt
ist auch eine welt wird für die frauen
das leben wirklich hart wird für viele
frauen das leben hart wird weil die
pferde sind weg oft sind die männer weg
immer wieder sind sie weg und das heißt
einfach extrem viel schuften
aber ich finde man muss das im vergleich
zu dem auch bewerten was in den ländern
um die schweiz herum an mehr als not
erlebten wird sie haben die frauen
dargestellt die quasi zu hause
übernehmen müssen sei es auf dem
bauernhof sei es in der gemeinde
sozusagen während man eben von den
männern im militärdienst sagte design
sozusagen ferienlager es gibt ja auch
lustige karikaturen war sie aufstehen
essen und dann hinlegen und warten und
wiederum essen und ausgang und das war s
dann ungefähr wie ernst hat man in der
schweiz die eigene armee genommen
irgendwo hat man sie ernst genommen aber
in diese mädels waren neutralität
schutzdienst für das ist eigentlich die
miliz gar nicht gemacht nicht die
einrücken und dann eigentlich wenn es
zum kampf kommt zu kommen können und
dann noch vier monaten fünf monaten
wieder nach hause und nun war ein teils
die idee da und und wähle da war
absoluter überzeugung es sind nicht die
waffen die entscheiden sondern die
erziehung der soldaten und da ist man zu
diesem trick um 7 erziehungsziel etwas
sehr problematisches in einer
staatsbürger mehr
da hat es probleme gegeben nicht
flächendeckend der letzten endes aber
das hat zugenommen vor allem 17 18
mit mit hinein ist ist das wirklich ein
problem geworden und ich denke da hat
die glaubwürdigkeit dann schon gelitten
wurde aber auch ganz stark vom in der
linken presse skandalisiert dass robert
klemm war ein spezialist in die
skandalisierung test habe ich eine
wichtige rolle spielen zu dieser zeit in
der linken bewegung vielleicht nicht
unerwähnt knappheit hängt ja mit dem
zusammen was die männer eben nicht an
entschädigung kriegen wenn sie
militärdienst leisten
und da wiederum diese kombination ich
habe das an einem bataillon mal verfolgt
das sehr genau beschreibt wie die durch
den krieg gehen dass er auf der us seite
ständig diese märsche das ist wirklich
dieses disziplinieren weil ich
motorisiert und das auch ja wirklich die
soldaten studien die entstehen müssen
fasst diese innovation dass die sie
einen ort haben wo sie sich nicht nur
betrinken als dass sie das wenige geld
das sie einst die kriegen ja wirklich
quasi nichts und es gibt keinen
erwerbsersatz das ist eine ganz wichtige
erfahrung vom ersten weltkrieg
und dann gibt es dann diese soldaten
stunden da hat man einen euro
wissen sollte und stichwort serien lage
es erstaunt uns nachträglich das
eigentlich die armee riecht die
unterkünfte an der grenze für die
soldaten der acht primitiv hielten dass
man sich nicht vorstellen kann wie diese
menschen in den leeren scheuren scheunen
oder käse kellern die freizeit
verbringen konnten
und wenn vorher im fall dieser
gemeindeschreiberin oder vor bald drin
die bedeutung durch die wachsende
bedeutung der frauen angesprochen wurde
finden wir ja hier wieder es ist ja ein
fräulein spieler die dann nach diese
zyklen wird die weil ich dieses ganze
system auch mit mit sprecher zusammen
aufbaut das ist ein privates unternehmen
und die die frauen leisten da etwas ganz
wichtiges konkret aber sie erleben auch
selber ihre organisationsfähigkeit
allerdings werden sie dann enttäuscht
weil sie eigentlich als den erwarteten
preis nämlich dass frauen schlicht gar
nicht bekommen und die setzen um gegen
sich schöne produkt der soldaten stuben
katja bis heute in der schweiz in
demokratie ist wie das falsche
die kantinen in den großen alkoholfreien
restaurants eben auch noch gegen die
während der im übrigen die hatten
natürlich diese konkurrenz liege sie
haben es angedeutet es gab auch zürich
als exil leben es gab künstler
schriftsteller die da waren
das war eine sorte von von ausländern
von emigranten in der schweiz es gab
aber auch kriegsversehrte es gab
verwundete die kam es gab
kriegsflüchtlinge
es gab verschiedene menschen die aus dem
aus dem krieg sei ländern in die schweiz
strömten georg keis war die schweiz
damals aufnahmebereit gegenüber diesen
menschen oder nicht ich glaube ich mache
einen wesentlichen unterschied ob man
mit leute aufnahmen von denen man
einigermaßen sicher sein konnte dass sie
wieder gehen
also das sind interne der soldaten das
sind versicherte sollten verletzte
soldaten die übrigen deren unterkunft
auch von den herkunftsländern nachher
bis hinter das komma entschädigt wurden
und im übrigen die leerstellen stehende
hotellerie voll auslasten hals ist eine
ganz andere kategorie als dann die
zivilen privaten asylsuchenden und dann
ganz speziell auch noch die deserteure
haben wir bis heute hat die frage also
wenn man in der schweiz seit ich diese
akteure für die eigene armee nicht mag
wie soll man dann die andern dessert
töre da unterstützen die im übrigen zum
teil natürlich dem inferno einfach
entkommen wollten aber auch eine andere
politische einstellung hatten
und hier kommt dann auch die größere
nachbarschaft hinzu
hier tauchen plötzlich russen auf deren
sprache man nicht kann und da gibt es im
übrigen rühren die zeugnisse von bauern
die solche menschen aufnahmen aber hier
kommt dann eben auch mit dieser neu
erfundenen fremdenpolizei die idee dass
die schweiz welche rein gehalten werden
sollte es kommt auch das quarantäne
prinzip
es gibt eine mischung von medizin angst
vor medizinischen versorgung und
politischer verseuchung und dass es
diese gleichzeitigkeit von humanitären
schweiz und daneben wachsender
fremdenfeindlichen schweiz haben wir in
diesen jahren
sie haben die russen angesprochen ich
meine wir haben jetzt die schweiz ist ja
quasi innerhalb dieses krieg ist eine
eine ins leben auch wenn auf das noch
kommen aber die spannung der große krieg
findet außenstadt aber im innern haben
wir zunehmende spannung wir haben
schon ein bisschen gehört die die männer
im ferienlager die frauen übernehmen
müssen
sie haben angesprochen die preisstellung
die lebensmittelknappheit also woher
können wir uns noch ernähren
es gab dann zunehmend ein konflikt auch
zwischen den bauern und den soldaten
zwischen bauen und den arbeitern die in
den fabriken waren also es hat sich in
der schweiz etwas zusammengebraut das
dann eigentlich ein landes streik 1980
entladen hat da treffen streikende
arbeiter aufeinander
aus der ganzen schweiz in der ganzen
schweiz aufgerufen wurden zu streiken
und truppen die general wille wiederum
quasi nach zürich geschickt hat um
sozusagen eine revolution zu verhindern
die er befürchtet hat dieser konflikt
sind sich dieser landes streiken
november 1918 der nicht ganz drei tage
gedauert hat und ein moment werde ich
der spannung war
was hat was sagt er über die damalige
schweiz aus ja ja mal aussehen es ist
ein teils ab beginn und 10 18 nicht gibt
es die die ganzen versorgungsprobleme
die nehmen zu politisch wird das
zugespitzt es gibt dann ein
aktionskomitee der linken die ab dem
sommer an kleine generalstreiks politik
verfolgt und es spielt sich tut man es
ist man sieht dann auch das kriegsende
kommend letzten endes nicht man muss
sehen sich die russische revolution über
die bühne gegangen vor einem jahr nicht
das hat natürlich links auftrieb gegeben
ja das ist so und und von rechts kam die
ängste auf und es gab dann zb zürich
zürich war wirklich das
gravitationszentrum dieser sozialen
politischen unruhen gab es eine bank
bern steigt er von der arbeiter union
die sehr links mal unterstützt
bankbeamten haben nicht gestärkt weil
sie hunger hatten sondern weil sie auch
das gleiche wollten wie die kantonalbank
aber die arbeiter union hat das benutzt
um mal zu zeigen genau streik in zürich
können wir dass die konnten es
und auch die tramp die drumsticks tempo
gefahren man ist die streikposten sind
herumgezogen haben die leute werden mit
auch die chance nach mit gewaltanwendung
also man hat dazu testen begonnen und
auf nationaler ebene hat man mit
minutengenauer streicht aber nun der
generalstreik selber das ist in meiner
meinung nach ist das ein unfall weil
eben wille sagt das ist ganz typisch für
ihn
prävention einschüchterung strategie die
zürcher regierung ist ein bisschen weich
geworden und hat eigentlich nie so recht
gewollt mehr drucken und als sie dann
wollte hat und wille noch das letzte
batterien ab und dann wollten sie und
dann hat er gesagt so jetzt präventiv
eigentlich wollte er nur die kavallerie
rundherum aber ich denke die zürcher
wollten eben darum die regierung ist die
kaserne gezogen ich glaube ich so viel
angst überhaupt im country haben um das
zu beschützen und am gleichen tag wie
das original komitee die tag tanken
das war mental mit robert kremers kopf
die haben in bern getagt und am gleichen
tag rücken in zürich 4 regimenter einen
präventiv und das löst im generalstreik
erst aus dann müssen die natürlich
reagieren machen proteststreik eine
einem tag aber die zürcher den radikalen
zu sagen nein weitergereicht und dann
kommen die unter zugzwang und müssen
eigentlich den generalstreik hier
ausrufen es hätte sein können wenn nicht
also zwei mal seht ihr unter zugzwang
gesetzt worden dass das vorüber gegangen
wären aber sie beschreiben das sehr
schön ich meine sie haben vorher auch
dieser diese exilanten beschrieben und
lenin lebte ja damals in der schweiz war
auch dann die sozialisten kräfte aber
trotzdem er war in der schweiz und es
gab auch wie sie gesagt haben diese
russische revolution die natürlich auch
durch die lande ging war das auch
irgendwie quasi ein spiegel dieses
großen dieser großen auseinandersetzung
auf dem kontinent zwischen bolschewisten
und bürgern wenn man so will der
bürgerlichen eliten
ich glaube etwas schon erwähnt habe
diese radikalisierung dass es da ein
teil von leuten gibt die auch eine kraft
werden rund um arbeiter union die
glauben in der phase ein stück weit an
die möglichkeit
revolution zu machen das ist aber ein
wirklich eine minderheit aber es gibt
dieses entscheidend sein für die
radikalisierung und dem was dann das
aktionskomitee auch eben reagieren muss
und nicht mehr agieren kann
und ja die frage ist ja war es ein
politischer oder ein sozialer konflikte
ich denke eben sozialwahl sicher also
wir müssen das so ist mit forderungen in
den generalstreik die letztlich zur
einführung der ahv gespürt haben zum
proporzwahl recht dass sie am anfang
erwähnt haben aber eben auch
frauenstimmrecht und sozialpolitisch und
das andere wäre politisch politisch das
heißt umkrempeln des ganzen des
steuersystems ist klar dass wir den
landesstraßen general landes streik im
zeitlichen engeren kontext als
unfallfahrer zu verstehen können
andererseits wenn wir die die lange
entwicklung anschauen dann dürfen wir
uns auch an die großen streiks vor 19 14
erinnern
und dann war eigentlich die kriegszeit
so etwas wie ein moratorium des
burgfriedens und was 19 herbst 19 18
wieder aufkommt ist nicht einzig jetzt
der bolschewistischen revolution
verpflichtet und nimmt etwas auf was
seit 1900 auch mit militärischen
einsätzen und großen dimensionen schon
stattgefunden hat und im krieg daneben
unterbrochen wurde und dann vielleicht
doch noch ein fachebene zürich ist das
zentrum und interessanterweise erfasst
ja dieser generalstreik eilig die
französische schweiz die auch mehrere
dort orientiert ist kaufen also weitet
sich aber doch endlich war in das gebiet
aus in grenchen kommt es zu drei toten
kommt es zu gewalttätigen
auseinandersetzungen
wir sind bald am schluss
macht mir doch mal einen bogen wir haben
gesprochen über die militärische
dimension wir haben gesprochen über die
wirtschaftliche gingen sogar auch nicht
nur die gesellschaftliche dimension wenn
wird heute nochmal uns erinnern an die
schweiz im ersten weltkrieg was hat die
schweiz damals geprägt was war das
selbstverständnis der schweizer was
wirkt daran heute noch nach georg reist
sie haben ihr buch betitelt die insel
der unsicheren geborgenheit die
geborgenheit hat diese weise nicht
bedroht war unsicher war es doch nicht
ganz aber dieses insel bild sind wir
deshalb eine insel war nach dem ersten
weltkrieg zu sehen haben sie das noch
belehrend ja auch beim bücherschreiben
und ich bin eigentlich mit mit anderen
vorstellungen die sache hinein gegangen
als ich dann am schluss auch im letzten
kapitel deponiert haben
ich bin überzeugt dass es wenn es so
etwas wie red wie mentalität gibt dass
wir das nicht nur einzig am zweiten
weltkrieg abhandeln können wir kommen
natürlich ihren kommt schwierige fragen
wie weit sie schicken welche intern
arisierungen in irgendeine kollektive
kultur wie sich das nachweisen lässt
aber das ist ja nach gläubigen und wir
haben ja vorher ist von diesem
bundeshaus auf der insel die rede
gewesen
es gibt auch belege dafür dass sich
diese jahre ausgesprochen
eigentlich als insel situation
verstanden wurden aber man konnte das
auch weil ich auf andere weise verstehen
also insel heißt eigentlich nicht dass
man dann ein planet für sich ist sondern
dass man hier auch der kommen schiffe
und gegen schiffe oder was immer da wird
auch angespült also flüchtlinge oder was
immer das wird ja dann von robert veh
sie auch so in einem gedicht erfasst
ich meine dass es keine starke
verschließung 1918 gegeben hätte also
ein einfacher beleg ist dass die schweiz
nachher in den völkerbund
gegangen ist und dass diese
verschließung er in den späten 20er und
30er jahren stattfindet und sich das
eigentlich dann weniger auch auf den auf
die kriegssituation bezieht der landes
streik von dem wir gesprochen haben
der ist der wesentlich stärkere
bezugspunkt so dass man eigentlich diese
frequenz besetzungs jahre sind mental
lange zeit fast namens land ein wenig
natürlich mit bewährung finden ihre
kalipreisen die schweiz die verschont
von diesen krieg wie hat sie dieses
verschont sein interpretiert das meine
ich eben aber da braucht das auch noch
mehr forschung das ist ein bisschen das
verhängnis von diesem ersten weltkrieg
für die schwarzen finish das schweizer
zeitverständnis man hat man ist aus
diesem krieg aus diesen kriegserfahrung
in europa herausgabe von wir sind
verschont geblieben
in kombination und wir haben es auch
maßgeblich selber gemacht und das ist
eher ein bild mit mit mit großer
langlebigkeit und daraufhin die schon
wird eben in der kombination mit diesem
insel bild das das da in der luft liegt
dass das da angelegt ist und in der zeit
danach dann zementiert wird dass man
eine insel ist die es besser macht weil
man man ist verschont geblieben und da
könnte ich jetzt noch die ganz lange
dauer von hinten her holen wir reden wir
überhaupt über krieg hier in diesem land
früher hat man schlachten geworden weil
gott auf der eigenen seite war und
nachher ist man verschont geblieben von
kriegen weil es der herrgott eben gut
mit einem meint und ich bin froh dass
jetzt über diesen ersten wirklich viel
gesprochen wird und es gibt
forschungsbedarf ich glaube auch wir
haben die chance jetzt mit einem noch
offeneren geschichtsbild mit dieser
kriegserfahrung auch wirklich eine
offenere diskussion zahlungssicherung
als im vergleich mit dem zweiten welt
motor und die letzte frage an sie was
bleibt bei ihnen haften wenn sie die
sich verteidigen der schweiz damals und
heute vergleichen
dass trotzdem vorbehalten die wir zu
beginn gemacht haben die schweizer armee
eigentlich 19 14 förmlich attraktionen
39 viel besser dastand dass sie dann
jahrzehnt eigentlich in den 1960 er
jahren das aufgeholt hatte was sie
verloren hat während den ersten märklin
nicht 1918 war die schweizer armee
eigentlich sie hat das alles nicht
mitgemacht und musste dann ein
aufholprozess den 37 jahren nicht nicht
geschafft hat muss sie dann machen ihn
im kalten krieg hoch gerüst und dann
kann natürlich das ende
und heute ist man suche nahmen am
versuchen natürlich sich auch diese
schweizer armee noch was sinnvolles zu
machen um das einzubringen in die
sicherheitspolitik was nicht einfach ist
georg kreis erika hinweisen
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
[Musik]